دمروا الحلم كله مسحوه عن بكره
ابيه فما ظل لا حلم لا طفل لا كبير لا
صغير كله تهدم كله
راح حرمونا من شبابنا من من طفولتهم
الاولاد هدول فالوضع والله جدا
ماساوي ما خلو لي لا حلم ولا مستقبل انا
24 سنه عمري انا كان نفسي اصير
تاجر تاجر عادي مونا والحمد لله تم
هدم محل المحلين تعوني كانوا دكان هدول
كانوا حلمي كانوا هدول اساس البيت رجعنا
لعصر الجاهليه للسفر الاقل من
السفر فالسفر لسه له مكان معين انا في
السالب
قصف الدار من هان نسيت كلمه السر تاعت
الجوال ونسيت لايلا كمان ومن يومها ل
اليوم لا انا الجوال ولا انا
بشتغل قالوا ب بدنا نقص في 11 فرج اللي
انتم فيه انزلنا نجر وطلعنا فرشنا حرماتنا
رحنا وقفنا في الساحه قبال الابراج وانا
متذكر حتى انا راحت بدي اضي جوالي عشان
اصور واوثق اللحظات الجوال مش راضي يضوي
وتذكرت موضوع الاي كلاود انا كاتبه على
الخزانه في الدار وهات زل ما يصل الدار
هات لي رغيف خبز وخذ
ال انا عبد ابو تؤى من مخيم الشاطئ من
الناس اللي طلعت فوق رؤس الشهداء واحد ي
قلت لما طلعنا احنا كنا عايشين ومبسوطين
لكن هلقيت احنا عايشين اطلع وين وهينا
بنترمولي وين نروح وابصر وين وصلونا يعني
نحنا كل اللي بدنا اياه بدنا لا تعمروا
لنا ولا تدونا رجعونا على دوره بنا نحط
خيمه وما بدنا شي من هالدنيا لا بدنا حلم
ولا بدنا حاجه كل حلم هلقيت نرجع
لبيتنا كان المفروض زي هذه الايام الحمد
لله بكون خاطب فكل دمروا لي كل كل حلمي
يعني ما خلوني لا مجال لا اخطب لا ازبط
بيتي طبعا هذا مش حالي لحالي يعني في حال
المواطنين
كثير نا 77 يوم لا ضحك
ز ولا اكلنا اكله زي الخلق قبلونا يا
راجل شاورما
يا يا عم احنا ما بدناش ناكل شاورما بنا
ناكل دقه بس رجعونا على غزه رجعونا على
دورنا فالوضع والله جدا ماساوي يعني احنا
ما مش جاي اشكي انه اقول لك رجعلي اللي
راح بس اطلع على اللي بده يروح
ثاني يلا هاته هان يلا
شاطر